all right everyone uh welcome to the
tdps seminar uh before we introduce our
invited speakers let's go over some
rules and Logistics first of all please
mute yourself during the talk but uh if
you have question you can unmute and ask
questions of course uh or you can use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in Q&A session at
the end uh second today's um ddps
seminar is open to external audiences uh
so no classify discussion okay and
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel um
all right that's about it let me briefly
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host Dr Nicholas B who is a
researcher fellow in mathematics at the
University of Cambridge he obtained a
PhD in numerical analysis in 20 2022 at
the University of Oxford under the
supervision of Patrick barell and Alex
Thomson his research focuses on the
intersection between numerical analysis
and deep learning with a specific
emphasis on learning physical models
from data particularly in the context of
partial differential equation uh he was
awarded a LLY Fox prize in 2021 for his
theoretical work on pde learning today
Nicholas will give an exciting talk on
elliptic pde learning that
is pro um provably data efficient before
I pass the button to Nicholas let me ask
a couple of question to Nicholas just to
get to know him better and make this
seminar somewhat informal um so Nicholas
I'm going to ask you couple of question
if that is okay all right uh the first
question goes you seem to be um very
passionate about data driven pde
learning and data approaches in general
is there any moment in your life when
you realize that wow this is it this is
the field I would like to commit my
career yeah well so I started to work on
uh numerical solvers for PDS and uh I
saw the rec like excitement about AI
machine learning uh mhm five years ago
and Bally the the lawnmark paper by
Kanis and hiss and physics inform
networks as well that we're first trying
to manage the field of machine learning
and and PD so I found it was very
exciting and started to work on these
questions as well okay good sounds good
the second question is would you tell us
one good thing about where you are right
now the University of Cambridge um well
I think good thing that is like the the
the great amount of researchers in uh
like the related areas that we have like
we have lots of people working on invest
problems and classes fre free Dynamics
and so it's always uh very interesting
to see and discuss with like such a wide
variety of of researchers here in the in
the University awesome well the floor is
yours
Nicholas yeah great so thanks for the
introduction and and thanks a lot for
the invitation to speak today so I'm
going to talk about uh PD learning and
this talk is based on a recent work with
my collaborators Di lias and Alex
Johnson who was my former PhD
supervisor and so before I thought I
would just give a very brief
introduction to the field of scientific
machine learning and so basically so you
you all aware of the like past and
recent successes of deep learning and
machine learning to various scientific
Fields uh like uh natural language
processing image
classification uh speech recognition and
so in the past few years so researchers
from numerical started to uh exploit and
work toward exploiting this B these
techniques from Deep planning and
combine them with uh natur uh with
numeric and and physics and so the idea
behind being that if we collect enough
data from physics experiment then we
might want to either simulate numerical
solvers or or learn mathematical models
for
experiments uh and so there's a a great
uh review paper by canakis and his qu Us
in these topics in in nature review
physics and physics information learning
and so in this talk we'll be focusing on
PD learning so there so I like to think
as uh scientific machine learnings as
being the combination of three main
research areas uh that are inzing uh
machine learning and partial
differential equations of pdes so the
first one is PD solvers then we have PD
Discovery and PD learning and so all of
them are different flavor of scientific
machine learning which are addressing
different problems so typically PD
solvers is aimed to construct uh M de
planning algorithms to solve unnown PDS
using data PD discovered is a try to U
find coefficient to discover
coefficients of a PD assuming that we
have a certain prior on the form of the
PD using for
instance the cind technique and finally
PD learning aims to discover
mathematical models from data with very
little prior knowledge of the physics
that simulates the
data and so the for instance of PD
discoveries I just want to illustrate an
example of potential application so this
is showing a picture extract from a
video of a surgery that people have done
on a p brain and for so from this type
of data we would typically like to
extract some bi iCal tissue properties
without having to perform expensive and
uh difficult
invo surgery and so this is typically
the field belongs to the field of invest
problems where from uh in undirect
measurements of phenomenon we would like
to extract some properties of tissue
Properties or if you are more from the
PD Community some coefficient like
diffusion coefficients happening in the
of the in the PD
another field is the another example for
another field for PD solvers is uh
that's a paper from K and in Canal in
2021 which shows the a f flow of npress
cup and so in this paper the authors
only have access to snapshots of the
temperature measurements of the fluid
above the espresso cup and from that uh
assuming that we know the underlying
equation that govern the data we would
like to infer all variables like the
flood velocity and the pressure and so
this is a great example of application
of the of the technique of a technique
called physics inform NE Network which
aim to train new networks to fit or to
approximate the solution to a given
known
PD and finally the last field which I'm
which is a field where I'm focusing on
is the field of PD learning or open
learning where we don't necessarily know
what the model is and we try to infer
the model so approximate the the action
of the model on some input data so
typically in this example we have a I'm
showing you a picture extract from a
simulation a fleet flow simulation where
the fle is coming a jet flow simulation
the fle is coming from the left at high
velocity and traveling to the right and
so if we are interested in applications
like material designs or
optimizations or fast simulations we
might want so we might want to build a
reduced order model of this system to F
just map the incoming boundary flid at
the left to the outcoming flu velocity
on the right without simulating the flu
the food model which might be very
expensive and so we might want to build
reduced a model using PD learning uh to
examp to speed up numerical solvers but
there are also occasions where we don't
know what the underlying physics is we
might just acquire data from from
physical experiments and try to build a
mathematical model using machine
learning and so in this talk we're going
to focus on PD learning and so in
particular we want to learn solution
operator associated with partial
differential equations of the form L of
U L you can think of L as a linear PD
where U is the solution and F is a
source St that excite the model so
typically what we have is we have
observation data so we f is like our
input to the system so it's like a
parameter that we can vary the function
that we can adjust we we send this
function to the system and then either
we perform a numerical simulation or we
perform a physics experiment and we
measure we acquire this underlying
solution so the response of the system
to our input F you and so the response
is dened as you that's the underlying
solution of the P that we assume to be
on
one and so the main contributions that I
will describe in this talk is first a
theoretical results that
quantify how many training data fnu are
needed for uh training those
systems and the second contrib in the in
the second part of the talk will be a
practical deep learning approach to
learn greens functions which are an
example of solution
operator and the key ideas behind our
our results will be based on numerical
linear algebra in particular randomized
numerical in algebra result concerning
regularity of GRE functions and rational
neur networks which I will disc
later and so there are several standard
approaches for PD learning
so typically so we aim to approximate
solution operators that are denoted by L
minus one which are operators between
functions and so the classical approach
is that we select we sample random
functions
F and then we acquire Sol Associated
Solutions U and from this pairs F and U
we want to approximate the operator that
takes in any function f and return the
following solution and so the way
researchers are doing that now is that
they approximate they build a new
network model to that approximate this
operator and the ne Network model is
called a new Operator by analogy of
being a new network in infinite
Dimensions so mapping between functions
instead of mapping between real values
and so while it's expensive to train
these networks the idea is that once the
network is trained then it's extremely
fast to evaluate often faster than
standard numerical
solers and so the classical approaches
for doing that are the Deon the for NE
or the Deep green and there are also
lots of recent papers and proposing
different techniques for building
neur and so essentially all these
approaches def by the type of neural
network architecture that is being used
so the Depon net is based on two fully
connected new network the fre neur
operator is based on convolutions and
the fre trans fast transform while the
Deep green approach is based on auto
encod and so depending on the prior
physics that you have on the operator
you might want to prefer using one one
approach or another but all of these
approaches are essentially trying to
approximate the solution operator with
different PRI the type of architectures
that they
use and so there are different
challenges right now that we see in PD
learning so first is uh the lack of
theoretical results so there are
different uh questions that we I want to
uh to look at which are for instance
what type of training data and how much
training data is needed to train these
neur operators getting rigorous
performance guarantees with reg s bonds
understanding what type of ne arit new
network AR are better than others so
these are typically approximation the
questions or whether these approaches
are robust toward noise
peration there are also some practical U
ISS practical challenges uh related to
the uh interpretability of the model so
the approach that I mentioned are
essentially blackbox in the sense that
these new networks object are very
complex and so it's very difficult to uh
get some interpretations once we have
training model because since those are
related to physics application we might
be interested in uh we might be
interested in extracting physics
Knowledge from a model such as dominant
modes governing the system Behavior the
symmetries conservation law Satisfied by
the system all singularities shocks
location and
Etc and so in this work we'll focus on
understanding uh trying to understand
how much data do we need uh to learn
solution
operators and so in this so I I just
first want to show you this experiments
that I did where I train three type of
neur operators to approximate the
solution operator of plus equation so
that's a very simple model just like a
to model on in in in two Dimensions uh
just to to test the behavior of these
models and so what I'm doing is I I
Generate random sour SS F to laan U
equals F and then I uh simulate the
solution I solve the PD the associated
equation to get the solution you I train
the different models for different size
of the training data set for for
different numbers of training data and I
about the testing error that we get the
relative testing
error so typically we we see see like a
sharp decrease in the testing error as
the size of the training data set
increased towards 50 and then U kind of
a the stagnation of the of the eror
towards 5% relative
error and so here this is a kind of a
very interesting observation in the
sense that we don't need that much data
here we need like something like a 100
or 50 source and for for Sy them to
approximate solution operator well with
5% error or 2% error and so this
constract with the vast amount of data
that is being used to train traditional
uh applications of De planning such as
for image class classification or
natural language processing so I have a
question Nicholas here when you generate
the data the sampling procedure is also
a um
factor of this performance measure yeah
whether you use the uniform sampling
light and hyp Cube sampling yeah I'll
talk about that a bit Yeah it depends on
how you what kind of distribution you
use to sample the The Source temp for
sure okay okay so yeah so key question
is to understand how much train data do
we need to learn a PD and so there are
several Works uh recently that have been
studying this kind of behavior as as
well and so first here we'll focus on uh
to to try to understand this question
we'll focus on linear differential
equations of the form L of U equals F
where we know that there exist we know
the form of the solution operator so we
know that the solution
operator is an integral against Green
against an object called the green
function and so we know that if you if
you know the green function here then
you can express the solution operator as
the solution to the PD as U equals
integral of G * and G is basically
represent the solution operator to the
PD so if we know G then we know the
solution
operator so as an example if we look at
the pon equation with homogeneous
directly upon a condition then we have
this GRE function below and so it's
interesting so we from the green
function we can read certain physical
properties of the underlying equation
such as the symmetries are related to
the Symmetry to the fact that the the PD
is s joint or the boundary conditions
can also be red on the green function
and this is the same for a more slightly
more complicated example which is Helm
equation in 1D where we can read the H
mod frequency on the wave length of the
green function as
well and so in our case we'll consider
elliptic equations in three dimensions
of this form so diffusion type models
where a of X here is a matrix of
coefficients and uh so we don't know
what the coefficient functions is and
from uh this equations we would like to
learn uh the corresponding solution
operator or the green function so we uh
excite the system with different Source
term F we read the solution U and then
from that we would like to approxim IM
derive an algorithm to approximate the
greens
function and so our main
theem states that uh there exist a
randomized algorithm so men construct a
randomized algorithm which converges
exponentially fast to the greens
function with respect to the number of
uh training data that we use and so the
the algorithm is random because we used
a random Source term sample from a
certain go process that we
characterize and we also because it's
ROM as so we we get a bond a cical bond
with a certain probability of success
and we show that the probability that
the bond fails is ex exceptionally small
so it decrease exponentially fast as
well as you uh increase your amount of
training data and so the proof that I
will describe later on the slides
combines different techniques from
numis and generalize them to infinite
Dimensions so it combines randomiz
single value DEC composition archical
matrices and
ping so now we'll go through the proof
so through the different aspect of the
proof to construct the algorithm that
converges to the gra
function so first we'll go through
randomiz algebra so if we have so we'll
come back to finite Dimensions first and
then explore how we can extend these
results to infinite dimensions and Ling
grein functions so first if we have a
matrix a then we know that we can write
down its singular value
decomposition and that the aarum theorem
tells us that the best onek
approximation to a is given by the
truncation to the case singular value
and the error is given by this Epsilon K
here is given by the tail of the
singular
values and so a laark paper by hco
Martinson and chop in 2011 called the
randomiz
SVD tells us that if we have a blackbox
matrix a that we can only access through
ma Matrix Vector product then uh we can
construct construct a low rank
approximation to a from random input
vectors and in the paper the auor con so
so describ this algorithm and also prove
rigorous uh convergence uh rigorous
results uh to guarantee that the that
the algorithm converges and in
particular it shows that the probability
that uh the U the approximation is close
to a is very large and the bond depend
on the best FR approximation error
Epsilon K and if you compare again the
best approximation the basically the
randomized SVD algorithm performs on
slightly worse than the best FR
approximation so in blue it's a r m SVD
to approximate low Matrix and in black
is the best approximation as I increase
the number of sample
vectors and so the uh so in
traditionally in the randomiz VD the
random input vectors are sample from a
gan distribution and here we're
interested in externing these results to
correlated Cent vectors so that we can
later extend them to infinite dimensions
and so that's what we did in our you
know in a paper with with Alex Johnson
two years one a year
ago where we essentially extend the
bonds from the paper by Al chop so that
we allow the ROM asvd to work when we
have a correlation between the in
between the entries of the input vectors
so we have essentially the same type of
C except that we have a factor here beta
K gamma k that depends on how correlated
the input vectors
are and
uh a nice feature about this
construction is that this additional
Factor here the fact that we allow this
additional flexibility so the fact that
we allow for correlation between the
input vectors in the ROM MD allow us to
enforce prior knowledge of the Matrix a
that we want to approximate into the
design of the Coan Matrix from which we
sample the random input vectors and so
if we have some prior knowledge on a we
can basically enforce that into a
construction for the random vectors and
in some uh in some occasions we can get
better approximation error than the ROM
that's what the plot shows on the right
on the on the right where we normalized
the error by the best approximation
error and in some cases using a
carefully constructed random vectors we
can get four 40 to 50% better
performance compared to the random
SVD and so now that we have this
generalization we can basically extend
it to infinite dimensions and to
operators and so we'll consider he M
operators which are bonded operators
between Banner spaces with finite norm
and so the essentially what we uh the
idea is that the H met operator are the
natural generalization of matrices two
infinite dimensions in the sense that
they enjoy the same property so the H
bit Norm for an operator is equivalant
to the fous norm of matri so it's the
square root of the trace of a St
a
and so they can be seen as integral
operators if you want so instead of
having Matrix Vector product we can have
integral of G of XY * F of Y and the two
behave in a similar
way and so they have nice property so if
you have like ANM integral operator then
the HB Norm is the norm of the kernel G
is L2 normal is equal to the can normal
the canal
G we also have a singular value
decomposition for H
met and we also have an mem which St
that if we trun the
SVD we also obtain the best
approximation in the he bit n which
which is the analog of the
F and so essentially what we have here
is that we have all the ingredients for
extending the that we have for the
randomized SBD for matrices two Infinity
Dimensions with f b m operators so now
instead of of
approximating computing a low low rank
approximation to blackbox Matrix a from
uh random from Matrix Vector products
with random input
vectors we can uh compute low rank
approximation to can G from integral
against random functions F sample for
ation process and the idea is that
because we have this nice theoretical
setup all the algorithm and the the
extends really very naturally to
infinite
dimensions and so now we have instead of
having coal Matrix we have a covalence
canel from which we can sample random
functions from the associated gion
process and the choice of the Coan
kernel will influence the distribution
of the random functions and the
approximation error rate that we observe
at the
end and so that's our theem then so if
we have a canel g then we can construct
an
approximation using a certain number of
random input functions sample fromion
process
that's basically satisfy this error Bond
where Epsilon K here which is the main
error Factor depends on the best onek
approximation to G so it depends on how
F the singular values of GDK and this
gamma K Factor here uh is basically
determined by the choice of the coant
Kel so how appropriate is the coant Kel
for learning the dominant singular
vectors of the kernel G
and so this is uh showing an application
of the random SVD for H me operator so
on the top left we have the exact canel
that we want to
approximate and on the bottom right this
one is a learned canel from the ROM
SSV and so in this example I'm using
random functions sample from the squ
exponential canal with different length
scale parameter so in left in red I'm
using a very small length scale
parameter and in blue blue and green I'm
increasing the length scale parameter
and as I vary the length scale parameter
we see that we obtain different relative
error and that a small length scale
parameter here is better for learning
this canel because it's not the agon
values of the cence canal will Decay
more slowly and so we are able to
generate a larger finite dimensional
Vector space of ROM functions for
approximating the
Canon but if we choose the length scale
parameter correctly we can approximate
this complicated canel to nearly machine
Precision with the
RVD and so now that we have this
generalization of the
RVD we can apply to learn a grein
function and to construct an algorithm
for learning grein functions so we have
this grein function here uh we uh use
the romd we compute integral against the
random functions that we sample and then
we apply the bond that we der where we
have to characterize what this Epsilon K
Factor here in other sense we have to
understand what half the singular values
of the green function
DK the problem that we observe here is
that the GRE functions are not smooth
near the diagonal so in 1D there is a
discontinuity in the derivative and in
higher Dimensions so in three dimensions
green function are take even infinite
values along the diagonal which is
problematic in this case so this
basically the fact that the GRE function
are not analytic and they're not smooth
tells us that this Epsilon K theyes very
slowly with K so in particular Epsilon
KES algebraically with K while we want
to reach an exponential convergence rate
to match what we observed in the deing
experiment that I showed
earlier so how do we solve this so we're
going to explore
regularity results about the green
function and so in particular we go back
to a paper by bof and H bush 20 years
ago that show that even though green
function are not smooth and they're not
low rank on the global on the entire
domain they admit a low rank structure
on well separated subdomains so if I'm
taking green function here the on the
cube in
3D if I if I restrict it to two
subdomains that are well separated such
as the green and blue domain then we
know that on the cross product of this
subdomain the green function is smooth
globally smooth and will be low rank but
if I take two domains that are attached
to each other such as the green the blue
and red domains so these two domains are
touching each other here the green
function is not smooth so these are
domains that are Li along the diagonal
of the tons product Omega cos
Omega and so if we look at a
onedimensional picture here so this is a
GRE function for 1D equation so the GRE
function is a two-dimensional
object this is in this case I'm coling
domains that are well separated so I'm
doing what's called the hierarchical
refinement so if I take two domains that
are well separated I color them in green
and if they're not well separated I can
do a division a subdivision of domains
and look at whether the children are
well separated or not so if we we start
from away from the diagonal and then and
then we progressively ref find the
domain as they go smaller and smaller
towards the diagonal to capture the
different low rank domains of the green
function and so now that we have that
now that we have this retical
construction the idea is that we can
look at each green domains where the
green function is low so because it is
low it's well approximated by a low
function and this tells us that this the
singular values the tail of the singular
value so this Epsilon K here is smaller
than Epsilon and DEC extremely fast with
respect to K so this the singular values
DEC exponentially fast with respect to
the rank K
here and so in particular this tells us
that we can apply the randomiz singular
value DEC composition on each thir
domain and get a very good approximation
to the green function with a low number
of one of training
data and so what we do now is that we do
it in a gical way in the sense that we
first learn the higher the larger
domains first and then we progressively
ref find go down to the YY go down the
YY and we'll find the results towards
the
diagonal so we have a we we use a clever
algorithm called the peeling algorithm
that have been proposed by like singing
and collaborators and Martinson as well
about 10 years ago that allows us to
reuse as much training data for the
random SVD as possible to exploit the
yal structure of the domain and don't
and limit the number of data that we are
using in our
algorithm and so now that we have that
we just have to deal with the case of
the diagonal so we just have to deal
with the red subdomains here now that we
have approximated the green function on
each green domain with the one is
V and so what we are doing now is that
we we look at uh characteristics of the
green function so how the green function
Decay away from the diagonal to
characterize the the magnitude of the
green function on this red domains here
and here we explored another result from
elliptic PD Theory from G and vidman in
1982 which tells us that the green
function are smooth and the decay of the
diagonal with a certain rate one / xus Y
and so if we integrate over this area of
the
subdomains then we can basically
essentially construct yal structure
refine along the diagonal until the
green function
becomes in magnitude becomes smaller
Epsilon and this case we truncate and
approximate the F by zero and make
Epsilon and so this procedure andure
that we basically make Epsilon on each
subdomain so when we reconstruct the
green function we make Global L
Epsilon and so in summary we we show
that our algorithm achieves exponential
convergence rate with respect to the
amount of training data so it doesn't it
doesn't require a lot of training data
which match uh the experimental behavior
that we observed before and so this tell
us that the if we consider the class of
elliptic partial differential equations
in in the form that I should diverence
form this class is data efficient in the
sense that we can construct a regor
algorithm that achieve exponential
convergence for learning any greens
function associated with this class from
input and output
data and so our construction exploits
the random ssvd and generalize it to
infinite dimensions and as well as uh
properties elliptic properties elliptic
regularity properties of the of a grid
function such as its gical low
structure and uh something interesting
to mention is that some of the
techniques that I described earlier so
the randomiz VD and the
archical
approximation naturally extend to other
type of equation such as time dependent
PDS of this form so you can think of it
as heat like equations so we have a
recent paper that describe how we can
EXT this technique next to them
dependent PDS as
well and so now in the second part of
this
talk I want to talk a bit about uh deep
learning application so where we use uh
this type of uh greens function learning
to design algorithm an algorithm a deep
practical deep learning algorithm for
learning the green function in
practice and so what we do is that
we first uh start with the point a here
where we select
a Coan Kel so typically squ exponential
Kel withle random functions that we use
to excite our system in b and c and
observe or measure the corresponding
solution so we typically do it by
numerical simulations but you could also
do it on and practical data that you
acquire and then we formulate our loss
function that basically has an object
that is going to learn the green
function so in the in the L function the
NG here object is a neon Network that
ends to approximate the underlying green
function and so we consider with this
method simpler PD than the ones
considered by Depon
Oro but where we want to learn a
physical object so we consider simpler
PD but we want to extract more physical
uh understanding from this uh from the
model and so in this case we have a
network for learning both the homog
homogenized solution which captur the
bond recognitions
and the greens function as well which is
essentially the solution
operator and the idea is that once we
have learned the greens function then
you can extract a lot of pictures about
the underlying P so you can look at
potential symmetries of the green
function which are related to symmetries
of the underlying PD or conservation
laws of the
PD we can perform a signal value de
composition to extract the dominant
values and dominant modes are these are
related to the ones of the the underl PD
as
well or look at Singularity location and
so this last Point here is related to
the type of new network that we use to
learn green function so as I said
earlier green function are can be
singular and are in general singular
along the diagonal of the domain and so
in
particular um we can't really use
traditional neon Network to approximate
GRE function because these neon networks
B on on the r function
are bonded and so we found that using a
different type of new network called
rational NE networks which are NE
networks with rational adaptive
activation functions yet better
approximation result when train in this
setting and so these new network can
have poles so in particular they can
take infinite arbitrary large values
which is ideal for learning GRE function
which are un bonded object and also the
support fure instruction in the sense
that you can visualize ize the poles of
the underlying rational functions of the
underlying rational networks to estimate
whether there's a shock or Singularity
happening in the model I'll show you an
example in the next
slide so as an example if we consider
the 1D adion diffusion equation where
I'm turning on adion only on the right
part of the domain so I'm considering
this equation on the interval minus one
one I'm turning on the adicction part
with this blue term here only on the
right half of the domain I'm
training manual Network to approximate
the underlying greens function from
pairs of source F and solution
Z and so what I observe is obtain this
green function object here and so first
there are interesting things to consider
here so if we look at the green function
and we restrict it to uh the bottom half
of the domain the left bottom left part
of the domain then we recognize the
behavior green function that is
characteristic of diffusion of the
diffusion equation so we can tell that
there's a diffusion phenomenon happening
on this part of the do on the other hand
if we look at the upper right part of
the domain we can tell that this is
adion dominated as a function is has
larger values than the upper half of the
domain uh if we now look at the
homogeneous solution so first you can
see that there's a really good
correlation between the exact solution
and the one that we learn through by our
new network and now if we plot the Ral
functions that that approximate the
homogeneous Solution on the complex
plane so we even though it's a it's a
real function we evaluate the we can
evaluate the rational neon networks on
complex plane and we get this face
portrait on the on the right Bel on the
right and this face portrait tells us
that the the POS of the Ral functions
tend to Cluster towards zero so these
like dots these color dots that we see
these are represent the pose of the
underlying rational functions they tend
to Cluster toward zero where there's a
discontinuity happening in the
homogeneous solution and so this can by
looking at how far the P are clustering
we can identify some physical properties
of the underline
function so as the last example I'll
just uh
want to consider the stocks flow example
in a len cavities it's a a
two-dimensional Vector
example where on the top left first uh
I'm showing the exact homogenized
solution velocity field so this is the
magnitude of the
velocity and the bottom left is the
Learned homogeneous Solution by the on
network so we see that we have a very
good agreement even though we are using
a course grid for training on network
between the length and exact velocity
field and then on the right I I'm
plotting the greens function associated
with this system with the stock flow so
what I'm taking as input here is the X
and Y component of the source stem of
the body Force St and I'm trying to
learn the operator that Tes in the left
and right component FX and FY and output
the left and the the first X and Y
component of the of the underlying
solution velocity
fi and so in this case because we have a
system that takes in two functions and
output two functions we have a what's
called a matrix of green functions which
uh basically takes these two components
and after convolutions output the two
components of the Velocity field these
are the G11 g12 g21 and
G22 and the interesting part is that by
looking at the system at the Green
function and the symmetries we can
understand first symmetries of the
system and how the X and Y component of
the Velocity are correlated with the X
and Y component of the source and how
the
system correlates and Co corate those
components and so to conclude so uh in
this talk I described a Ser for loading
greens functions so we we show that we
can achieve exponential convergence when
learning wind function which is in
agreement with uh with
stateoftheart numerical simulations de
planing simulations that have been
performed in the past few
years then we constructed the
generalization of the one Mass singular
value de composition to infinite
dimensions and he me
operators and also I descried the Deep
learning approach we have a a package
available in tlow for learning green
function that use questional your
networks and so with that I'll conclude
and thank you for your attention and I'm
happy to take any question thank you
thank you so much for the wonderful talk
Nicholas um let's have a Q&A
sessions awesome um I don't see any
question in chat room for now but that
doesn't mean you don't you don't you
cannot um ask questions let me start
with my questions so is it uh only
applicable to linear elliptic problem
for now or can it be yeah so uh so this
main that I disc discovered is for
linear elliptic problems because uh we
need some underlying results on
regularity C that is done for tic
problems and can also be extended to
parabolic systems so the equations like
are similar to the heat
equation uh a key question of course is
to a key challenge for the future is to
extend these techniques to hyperbolic PD
which would be very challenging and also
nonlinear problem so that's that's the
key open questions for the Futures to
get some theoretical Rael to
quantify sample complexity of PDs for
yeah hyperbolic systems and non nonar
PDS as
well okay um and also I have a
impression that this only works for the
uniform
mesh uh no uh no so actually um or the
cian No No so in in the in the last
function here I have this integral
operation so we have this green function
that takes X and Y as input uh you can
disti uh you can take any quad as you
want so you can Discord your mesh your
domain as you want take any quad your R
and that that that would work so if you
if you don't have any strong appr on the
domain you can use like a multe
approximation and take ROM points in
domain but you can you can also look use
more like high order and more fancy qu
you would see if if you have access
to
okay awesome um can you tell us about
what kind of like speed up you you
obtain yeah so the the yeah so the
theoretical we that we have is uh is not
meant to be applicable in practice so we
uh because uh constructing the the
archical scheme could be constructing
the yo structure could be quite
challenging if you have complex domains
so it's mostly there so we we mostly try
to
understand what type of distributions of
source terms are interesting in
applications and try to justify give a
regor guarantees for existing
state-of-the-art deing
techniques uh as for the speed up so
it's it's still an ongoing uh ongoing
works right now to really evaluate those
techniques again classical solver so I'm
I'm not really advocating that we we
should use these techniques to speed up
numerical solvers but I'm more confident
in the in their utility where we don't
know we don't have a model for them so
I'm I'm I prefer to to I prefer to use
neurer techniques for cases when we
don't have any model like for instance
there are recent applications in the
team by in by Deep mind and in Caltech
as well to wether forting where we don't
necessarily have a good model for for
weather forecasting and they and they in
this case they achieve some huge speed
up compared to existing
techniques a awesome awesome okay so for
example weather forting if you want to
use this method um probably the data we
collect is hu yeah so if you can talk
about the scalability of this this
method as the data uh size
increases the cost of you know learning
those greens functions as it scale larly
or uh yeah so I believe here uh it's h
yeah I mean yeah I believe this uh would
scale linearly yeah I mean uh the the
training of the new network yeah I
believe this would scale linearly and
the world point is that uh because we
have like such in this case prior
information you don't need much training
data as well because the idea is that
because the PD and the solution operator
has a lot of structure in practice you
don't need much training data to train
them so the experiment I showed
here uh Tod with stock flow we are only
using like a 100 source and solution
terms
well I I don't think the the neural net
training cost is scale linearly with the
data size you have to solve a non
optimization
problem
um
well well because you uh if you do like
batch uh F like batch batches like batch
optimization I think the at each Epoch
uh the number of iterations that you do
over your badge set is increase linearly
with respect to
the uh the underlying data set size so
all the updates that you are doing like
stent updates is fixed and doesn't
doesn't uh depend on the data set size
and then each patch each uh yeah in this
case this will this will SC this would
scale L with respect to the the size of
the training
data yeah the problem is you know when
you increase the data size you know the
the parameter you have to introduce
weights and biases in the neural network
it
increases yeah well so the number of
unknowns in your nonlinear optimization
problem is increasing and yeah sure but
um yeah uh but yeah I'm not saying that
uh I'm not saying that this method
should uh compete like are trying to
replace standard classical numerical
solvers that have been heavily optimized
I think these methods are interesting in
the case where we don't have any
alternative we don't know what the model
is I we need to discover some we want to
discover some Physics that that's really
my my point on this on this class of yes
I mean yeah in that sense this method is
very promising um okay
um any questions from audience me unmute
yourself and ask your
question oh I asked a question in the
chat oh you did yeah I I did not I don't
see any oh oh sorry about that I missed
that um
yeah um well question about question
from ruie he asked Can you comment on
the relation of your method to
F yeah um okay
so um yeah that that's a great question
so the fno in a
sense uh is also trying to learn like a
can like a GRE function in you want if
you want but it's uh doing several
layers so it's it's like a
it's if you want our method can be seen
maybe as like a one layer F where we
don't do extra so in the do extra
approximation extra simplification the
type of Kernel that they use using the
for convolution so our method does is a
more simpler than f it only works for
it's much more limited because it only
works for linear PS but then we allow
for learning a much more diverse uh a
much more diverse class of Kels so
because we construct an object to learn
the green function here the advantage is
that we can really visualize the object
that we get while the feno is kind of a
more like a blackbox new network arure
so it's much more difficult to extract
some
understanding so yeah our approach is
more like a a one layer can be seen
maybe as a one layer fre operator where
you replace the convolutions by by uh
this your network G
here awesome related related to that um
how about um you know compared to the
like the cind um yeah so yeah that's
yeah another great question so the so
the Cindy approach is basically so you
remember the the beginning of the
talk uh where
show this figure
here MH so uh
fonet and and our approach are in PD
learning on the PD learning
side uh pins is in the PD solver so
physics from neur neur Network and the
cind approach is more on PD Discovery so
they have some knowledge of the type of
equations that they want to recover and
they try to learn coefficients of the
equation so the cind approach in a sense
is complementary to the PD learning
approach so they have stronger prior dat
stronger prior on the type of physics
that they learn but they try to recover
different information so these are these
two are complimentary
approaches okay um I mean I I I would
view it like
Cindy as a you know OD learning or the
PD learning
as well um well it does give you some
differential equation form of yeah
exactly so I call it PD Discovery in the
sense that you are trying to solve the
inverse problems while learning you
learn the forward problems with the
solution operator but the form is not PD
right it's a no it's not a PD but uh if
if you train if you uh use a CD approach
and you learn the PD you still have to
solve it afterwards sure sure but but
but both of both of them are you know
once the training is done like the
discovery is done you can use those
model to replace the
or um you can use that as a model to
find out the new Solutions and yeah you
you still need to solve the equation
exactly but the P Lear okay so your
point is for the PD learning yeah are
exactly so those are really
complimentary uh they will give you
different type of information about the
PD the cind approach gives you more
physics information because it really
gives you the coefficients of the PD
while the uh operator learning or PD
learning approach like fno gives you
more like a fast server which may be
very useful for optimization uh task
Downstream for instance got you got
you well thank you ni plus is there any
other question
question I have a question regarding the
linearity of these PD problems I'm Tony
uh so just to make sure I understand
what you mean by linear problem suppose
you have two forcings A and B and then
you have a new forcing that's a linear
combination of A and B um do you expect
the response to be the same linear
combination of the response that came
from A and B respect
L yeah okay then in that case if you
collected enough forcing and response
payers and your goal is to solve for a
new forcing um can you somehow just find
the best linear combination from the
data like you use a linear combination
of the forcing from the data to
approximate the new case and the same
linear combination of the response we
just gave you the best of the response
am I thinking about that problem
correctly uh yeah possibly but I guess
if you do that uh I'm guessing that
that's possibly equivalent to finding a
low rank approximation to your to your
problem and so that will uh converge
quite slow so there might be better ways
than just uh trying to find a low like a
small uh a small number of functions in
your data set that desb your data there
may be better ways
of to to compute the solution than just
comput an approximation on this on this
small
subset I see and is is the is learning
the gra function uh a way to impose
constraints yeah
so yeah exactly so if you uh so what
what we do here is that in our algorithm
we enforce theal uh structure of this of
the green function and so there are
different approaches so all the operator
learning approaches that have been
proposed recently like the F dionets uh
in a way they are all related to Green
function and they all enforce different
type of structure on the on the model so
if you if you know the type of structure
of the green function like it is low
rank it is it has a yo structure it
decays away from the diagonal you can
select your new network architectures to
enforce this constraint uh strongly when
you train your
network okay thank
you thank you Nicholas is there any
other
question well if not let's thank our
speaker Nicholas for the wonderful talk
and um nice discussion in in Q&A
sessions and yeah thank you so much
Nicholas yeah wonderful um let
[Music]
me stop the recording